unsere wer wunderbare Rubrik
Fragenlotto wir haben grüne und rote
lose ich weiß nicht haben sie es gesehen
schon dann wiüssen sie ja ich freue mich
schon super
zugreifen wie gesagt die Fragen sind von
Unkenntnis geprägt und Sie müssen nicht
antworten ich muss nicht nein nein auf
keinen
Fall echt sind sie wirklich so
schüchtern wie sie
aussehen schtern aus sie schüchtern aus
mE etwas falsch ich will wild Aussehen
wild und se schüchtern aus se schüchtern
aus echt die ist nicht von mir ich weiß
jetzt nicht wer sich die wieder
ausgedacht hat ich bin irgendjemand
meinte wohl dass sie schüchtern
sind ja es ist ganz interessant weil ich
bin eigentlich nicht schüchtern und gehe
eigentlich immer sehr ran auch so an die
Leute und frag frag frag frag frag und
dann gibt's ein Punkt wo ich dann ganz
schnell ganz schüchtern werde ach und
der ist wo
ne bei Frauen z.B ist es schon so eher
die Nummer dass ich sage irgendwie ne
nee doch nicht und Tschüss also ich bin
eher
so ist das schüchtern oder ist das
Moment jetzt wird es ernst gar nicht
vielleicht auch das aber ich ja ich bin
so beides glaube ich ich arbeite noch
dran fin schüchtern aber okay aber ich
sehe nicht schüchtern aus schockt mich
jetzt
bisschen tut mir ich das von wie sehen
Sie denn aus
also wie se ich aus noch viel
schüchterner sind sie
schüchtern ja ja ne schon doch doch also
ich vi auch jeder Mens man wenn man wird
man dann eh hat es was damit zu tun dass
sie dann der Fragende wurde und nicht
der
gefragte dass ich der Fragende wurde ja
und nicht der Befragte also dass sie
jetzt da sitzen und nicht hier dass ich
nicht ist auch ein Komplex vorhin haben
wir drüber gen D komplex ist d ja ja ja
das kann natürlich sein so nach dem
Motto sonst würde ich mich gar nicht
trauen Fragen zu stellen ja ja wobei ich
glaube es ist schüchternhheit ist
vielleicht eine Grund Grundeinstellung
des Menschen und es ist immer eine
Überwindung nicht schüchtern zu sein
oder man fragt ganz viel damit der
andere mit dem Antworten beschäftigt ist
und nicht auf die Idee kommt auch zu
fragen z.B wie z.B warum bekommen Sie
keine
Hauptrollen ja ja ich muss mal kurz mit
meiner Agentin telefonieren äh warum
bekomme ich keine ha es stimmt ehrlich
gesagt so nicht
es stimmt nicht ist bei solchen Fragen
ne stimmt nicht aber es ist auffällig
dass ich ganz oft best BU oder oder S
Kick bin oder wie der Amerikaner der
oftmals viel klüger ist als der Deutsche
vor allem im Mediengeschäft sagt
es ist irgendwie äh
ähm
ich habe jetzt den fahen verloren was
macht der Amerikaner beste ne
neendarsteller was sagt der Amerikaner
zum neben darstell supporting actor
unterstützender Darsteller und so sehe
ich mich schon also so habe ich meine
Aufgaben oft gut gemacht glaube ich also
die Hauptrolle unterstützt und irgendwie
alles dafür getan diesen Darsteller zu
zu auf aufs hohe Podest zu wuppen und so
finde ich ich habe sehr gerne immer die
Rollen gespielt die ich gespielt habe
aber ich spiele auch Hauptrollen z.B am
am 9 oktober in U900 ATZ schrüder Ivan
katfeld und ich werden ein großes großes
großes Abenteuer vor uns haben im Kino
wow ja wird cool spielt auf einem U-Boot
also die meiste Zeit haben wir in Rom
und Malta gedreht war echt geil echt
geil und eng und eng aber wird super
wird echt ein cooler Film heute abend
sehe ich ihn zum ersten Mal ist das
Comedy oder ernsthaft oder es ist
lustiger also Atze im Dritten Reich oh
Gott also es ist der
Versuch natürlich lustig zu sein also es
ist natürlich eine Komödie aber es hat
also ich spiele einen einen einen
verfolgten Juden auf der Flucht das wird
schon für Gesprächsstoff sorgen das
glaube ich auch und ist mutig
ja das war jetzt eine rote Frage die
nicht beantwortet wird das war da war
das die Frage von gerade eben was ah ich
weiß gar nicht also ist schon
weggeschmissen schon klar
h was ist mit ihrer rechten Augenbraue
los die Frage ist nicht von mir ich habe
mich die ganze Zeit gefragt was soll
diese Frage
ah weil die so weil die höhhe ist ein
bisschen
stimmt ja wer der Redakteurin sowas
nennt man Charaktergesicht hallo da ist
nichts
los ja darf ich eigentlich alle
aufmachen ja selbstverständlich ah jetzt
beginnt das
hier welchen Charakter spielen Sie am
besten ach alle
ehrlich ja
keine vorbalte gegenüber irgendeiner
Rolle ich hätte ein Probleme Triebtäter
zu spielen also das würde ich sogar
ablehnen weil es mich glaube ich
anwiedern würde
mich mich mit sowas zu identifizieren
oder zu beschäftigen aber
m also ich habe jetzt glaube ich noch
keine Rolle gespielt wo ich sagen könnte
die habe ich schlecht gespielt
ist nicht arrogant also nee finde ich
nicht ist es so selbstbewusst warum soll
man sagen
nee ich finde ich finde es gab keine
Rolle wo ich gesagt habe die war richtig
scheiße gibt also gibt's
nicht schön woher haben sie diesen
intensiven und doch so sanften Blick
tja schön
das nehme ich
mit sehr
schön auf der roten stand übrigens die
ich weggetan habe da stand übrigens
drauf wie haben sie wie haben Sie es
geschafft Ivon katterfeld
rumzukriegen was soll wir darauf
antworten wie das Frau katterfeld
geschafft mich rumzukriegen W viel
interessanter ich kann es mir inzwischen
vorstellen ja das war der Moment wo sie
schüchtern
wurden ein guter guter man hier Christop
Dings wann werden sie nächstes
Theaterstück
schreiben ja ich bin immer wieder dran
ich habe ein Theaterstück geschrieben
das ist jetzt 5 Jahre her das habe ich
auch dann wurde auch aufgeführt und so
und es war echt schön
ja ich bin leider also was wirklich eine
Schwäche ist
ähm ich krieg ich kann Dinge ich fang
ganz ganz viele Dinge an und kriegst sie
nicht zu Ende und da fehlt mir dann die
wenn ich ab dem Moment wenn ich weiß
also wenn ich ein Comedyprogramm
schreibe oder wenn ich ein Theaterstück
anfange zu schreibe oder so und ab dem
Moment wo ich weiß wie es aussehen
wird
dann hört's auf mich zu interessieren
das Interesse Weg ja das finde ich ganz
was schlimm dann ist es Arbeit ja ich
finde es ganz tragisch also doch ein
bisschen
faul ja ja vielleicht also da bin ich
dann faul oder ich habe Angst dass es
dann doch nicht so schön ist wie meiner
Fantasie ich bäuchte einen guten Partner
der mich da immer in Arsch tritt also
ein
Arbeitspartner was ist ihr
Lieblingsgericht
mein Lieblingsgericht können es wieder
abstellen mein Lieblingsgericht
ist ich esse leidenschaftlich gerne und
koche leidenschaftlich gerne und es kann
man gar nicht sagen ich bin einfach ein
wahnsinniger essensliebhaber und wenn es
gut gemacht ist dann liebe ich alles ich
bin genauso wie Orte ich bin totaler
Opportunist ein ortsopportunist immer da
wo ich bin will ich mal gleich leeben
ich find's überall toll das heißt wenn
wir sie jetzt in München interviewt
hätten hätten sie das gleiche über
München erzählt wie über
Berlin nee ja weiß ich nicht nee also
ich find es überall toll wo ich z.B im
Urlaub bin also wenn ich im Urlaub bin
z.B dann kann ich mir dann stelle ich
mir immer nach einem Tag vor wie es wäre
da zu leben so
also doch
begeisterungsfähig super vielen Dank